Yes, how are you?
This is Frank Defray is calling again for Patrick Boyd.
Sure, let me just get him for you.
Thank you.
Hello.
Patrick.
Hey, how are you doing?
How are you?
It's Frank.
Uh not too bad, you know.
Did you have a little time?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I called a little earlier.
They said you were out to lunch.
Yes, yes.
What did you have for lunch?
Oh chicken Caesar salad.
Slightly healthy, but uh the croutons, you know.
So Yeah, that sounds pretty good.
No bur no burgers and fries?
Yeah, so yeah, far away.
I sound far away.
No, no, no, no.
Fire away.
Oh, fire away.
Okay.
Got a little bit of an echo in your voice, but I think we're okay with it.
It sounds like you're in a large room.
It is quite a large one.
This is I'm in the conference room.
Oh, are you on a speakerphone?
No, no, no, not at all.
Okay.
Not at all.
I mean we could try back or No, this is fine.
I think it'll it it'll be fine.
Okay, alright, okay.
Why don't we start off?
I know you have a number of things coming up that's very exciting as far as some of your workshops, assuming that those are are still a go over there.
Why don't we start off with that and we'll get that information out to the folks that are listening uh right off the bat.
Okay, no problem.
As you n may know, there used to be um a holography school in this location uh some time ago run by Edwina Orr.
School Richmond School Richmond holographic studios.
Yes.
And uh so there was always classes here, and this is where I first came across holography as well.
And yeah, basically, um about ten years ago the premises was uh uh taken over by a company called Spatial Imaging, which is called Rob Monday and Jeffrey Robb.
Mm-hmm.
And uh but most of um they're they're traditionally a display holography company, but for the last I'd say eight years their work has been more digital, make digital holograms.
I see.
Now is that creating holograms directly from digital information or are you using some sort of an interface with a with a uh projection screen or something?
No, no, no, creating it digitally, printing it dot by dot.
That's an incredible amount of uh information that you're processing there.
Are are are you able to do that using just standard desktop computers now or proprietary stuff?
No, no, no, it's uh it's a standard desktop computer.
That's just that's amazing.
Yeah, no, it's it's they're quite good, and they've got a few technologies uh that use different methods, but basically it's yeah, printing the hologram pixel by pixel.
And that's mainly used for security imaging.
Yes, I imagine they're rather small holograms.
Oh no, up to fifty by fifty, something like that.
No kidding.
Yeah, yeah.
What time how much time does it take to print a hologram that size?
Because I know a long time ago in Holosphere and the the publication from the Museum of Holography, I think there was a company called Aerodine, and they were they were doing digital holography, and I think they were doing a centimeter by centimeter hologram, and I believe it took seventy two hours to print centimeter by centimeter.
Well, I think the biggest one here takes about eight hours or something.
Okay.
So they're quite big.
And um yeah, they're the yeah, they take overnight, I think, those things to produce.
Yeah.
And yeah, it's all done on photo resist.
Anyway, unfortunately this isn't my department.
My department's okay.
And uh so therefore they had these labs which they hadn't hadn't been the focus of the business, although they have done display work.
But it it is interesting that holography has gotten to the point where we can refer to a specific type of holography now as traditional holography.
Yes, I know.
Yeah.
Yes.
It is quite odd.
But then again, there are I think a lot a lot of people working in holography, and I know some of them actually that uh work with holog holography, but don't know traditional holography.
They're only digital holographers, you know, oh yeah.
There there's one here actually doesn't know about traditional holography.
Yeah, how about that?
Uh next we're getting old, Patrick.
Yeah, I know, I know, I know.
We're probably the old school here, doing it by hand.
I I imagine that your workshops are going to be for traditional holography as well, is that correct?
Yes.
Okay, so go ahead and have a moment, no entirely traditional holography.
Um, you know, the continuous wave laser, most of it, but we do cover the pulse slightly.
And yeah, very traditional, you know, on a very heavy table, you know, settling time and all that, you know, all about that.
Yeah.
And um yeah, so um so basically the labs were here and uh spatial imaging thought they'd like to get the labs used and thought that it might be good, you know, time to uh start the courses again.
Also, there's a renewed interest in holography.
Yeah.
And uh there are some new materials becoming available as well.
And uh so as far as recording materials.
Yeah, recording materials, yeah.
What's out there that's new?
Uh well the B B plate.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, so we've started using those.
Are they your preference?
Uh yes, yeah, they seem available and uh they seem to work.
They're not as fast as ACFA, but when you get them to work they're just as good.
They're beautiful.
Yeah.
And uh I've seen some very good work by Nyaki Bergstein using them, you know, full colour work.
Which is absolutely fantastic.
Now do you do any full colour work there with the uh continuous wave?
You know, we'll which is what a lot of full colour work is anyway.
Um but yeah, we we mess around with tea.
But at the moment we're in a kind of um young stage, you know, embryonic stage.
We're just we've just got the labs up and running.
We're offering the basic things in methods of teaching holography at the moment we're just doing beginners courses.
And at the moment I'm busy trying to set up a stereogram camera as well, so we can teach that method as well.
Which will be from a digital input so that's I see.
Yeah, so um yeah, we've got we've got the basics of a camera here which will um make it that much easier.
Bit of a shame, but there we go, you can't stop progress.
Yeah.
And then where people will be able to bring files, whether they're computer generated or film or photographs and scan them in and go directly from the computer.
That's the idea.
That's great.
How many how many images per hologram are you planning to use?
Oh, I don't know, fifty to a hundred.
I see.
Yeah, yeah, we've done three courses so far.
How long do they run?
Uh a week.
Okay.
And uh yeah, that uh at the moment we're scheduling 'em for the last week of every month.
And uh I haven't really advertised it yet, so everyone that's come along so far has been through word of mouth.
Now, if someone wanted to get information about the workshops on the web, would they go to your personal website or is there another website that you would recommend they go to?
There is another website and it is www.holograms dot UK and you follow the link from it says what's new.
Okay.
Okay, uh hopefully we'll get a a direct link 'cause we've after the third workshop we decided it had this school had to have a name, so we've come up with the London School of Philography.
Terrific.
Uh all the bills and I've got to um redo the web so uh that comes up on a search and hopefully it'll come up with we'll have to find out if London School is available or planted school of philography or something like that.
Mm-hmm.
Now, your your early work, why don't you tell the listeners that may not be familiar with Patrick Boyd from dare I say, maybe twenty year maybe fifteen, twenty years ago?
Oh golly, you know you're talking uh well, yeah.
Twenty years now since I've been involved in holography, I think.
Yeah, and you started out with um I guess what we would turn here here in the States, you did a lot of uh fashion portraiture, I imagine.
Yes, uh yeah.
Um well um I took uh the MA at the Royal College of Art in holography and uh came from a photographic background and I saw I guess my first holograms were actually photographic ones are the animated ones and um just animated images and for some reason then I was into fashion imagery, so I made animated fashion holograms which I perceived the end use being magazines and things like that, and then got involved in pulsed holography and got into portraiture and then started doing fashion imagery on that as well and uh did a shop window display for Zondo Rhodes and uh yeah, and things like that.
So large scale fa fashion images and um and then when I lived in New York, which was nineteen ninety or eighty-nine ninety, I uh changed direction totally and went back into photographic imagery and started making stereograms, i.e.
three D holograms, but again still using animation, but these were more of a documentary nature than anything.
So uh Was it uh was this on uh Mercer Street in New York that you did these pieces?
Yeah, the old museum of holography.
Yeah.
And uh so but basically what I wanted to do was make uh a type of imaging that was spontaneous.
Unlike, you know, most holography is stuff that uh you find or whatever and then there's a lot long deliberation process about making it a hologram.
So I wanted to do something that was totally spontaneous.
So I worked out a way of making holograms from a camera that I could carry myself all the time.
So I I took a photograph of thirty six photographs, one roll of film and then re registered them using an animation technique.
Yeah.
Of course, um nowadays, uh with video cameras and steady cams and uh registration software, this should be a lot easier.
Yeah, you register it on a screen.
Yeah, yeah.
Or maybe there's some software that can register it for you.
So I'm investigating that at the moment.
Mm-hmm.
Seems a shame though, because um one of the thing I like one of the things I liked about re registering the imagery was that it put some human contact back into the process.
Yes, it was is it was very much a skill involved.
Yeah.
Which I I'm sure, you know, doing it on a terminal is a skill.
Differ different skill sets, but still a skill nonetheless, but it's not as much I don't know if that's true.
I was gonna say it's not as much a hands on skill, but I guess it would be.
It's a tough thing, you know, it uh thing.
Yes.
But um I did feel that um with a lot of these processes if you take human intervention out of them so much then they kind of become slightly sterile.
Mm-hmm.
And it was always nice to have a bit of craft in it.
So anyway, maybe the craft will come somewhere else from the 'Cause when I was you know, re registering these images it's it was a a constant, you know, I didn't know how they would turn out until I actually started re-registering them.
Um 'cause when I looked through the images I'd decide what was going to be the focal plane and uh you could con so you could look at the image and say, right, that part there is going to be on the image plane.
Yeah.
Everything else is going to be for front or behind.
And you could choose that right at the end, really.
I mean when I shot it I obviously had a slight idea, but it often quite often changed.
Yeah.
So the registration of the images actually determines what's in the focal plane.
Absolutely.
That is very much a craft.
Yeah, absolutely.
And it was uh all the how you shot it was a craft, you know, and the re-registering.
I have a part of the website for little handmade portraits where we use a small amount of images, maybe about eight to ten, just to give a static three dimensional uh hologram and uh I I went through the same thing uh as far as trying to think of w what am I sacrificing if I want to go digital with this rather than just uh traditional photography.
Yes, yes, it it is uh it is a questi you know, a big uh issue really and um yeah, one that's gotta be broached there.
Mm-hmm.
But uh anyway, we'll see.
We will see.
I can always go back to the old hands-on method, but the last one I did, which was some time ago, um I seem to remember it took me about a couple of months to do because uh there were seventy two images which I uh well, two lots of thirty six I montaged the foreground and the background and the both the foreground and the background had to have corresponding maps.
So I I kind of montaged in the space.
And so that was uh a bit too much work.
I got too involved in the process, so this this'll give me a chance to step back a bit and maybe start afresh.
Yeah, yeah.
Now y I know I've been on a website of yours, it's a personal website that contains your photography.
Do you also have a website for the uh holograms so someone could see these?
I do.
It's rather out of date.
It's in uh it's in Jap well the one I did in Japan and it's actually on uh the Oh okay yeah I remember actually on the a guy called Earth Freeze rescued it from Japan and this is now on the um Konstitu for median website the K H M dot D E.
And uh I'll have to look up the website link.
Yeah I can do a search and uh find the URL because I want to include you know uh a link to you know some of your work to go along with the show as well.
Oh that that would be good.
I've got to update it.
It's rather old.
But um yeah no have to thank us for rescuing it otherwise it would have been lost forever.
Yeah.
Nothing's lost forever on the web.
I uh there's actually a few websites that go around and they spider all the websites that are in existence.
And they store it on their computers and you can go there and do a search and find websites that have been off the web for years.
Yeah.
So ever everything's still there if you can think so you've got to find it you gotta find it.
Do you ever think about coming to the States to do any of your workshop programs?
Um well we're gonna get this one off the ground.
Sure, sure, I understand.
People um have mentioned it and uh yes, of course I would be interested in doing I mean obviously there's a thing where you know holography is kind of equipment dependent and so you couldn't offer the whole thing and you could only offer what equip you know within the equipment available.
Mm-hmm.
But uh the idea is to try and get some teaching elsewhere and hopefully encourage some people to come to Richmond as well.
Yeah.
That might want to, you know, do the stereogram work or the pulse work.
Did you ever hear anything from Bardas?
I haven't heard from Bardas for years.
Yeah.
I think last I heard he was living in Oklahoma City or something.
Oh really?
Huh getting into Shiatsu but I haven't heard from for years.
Yeah it would be good to get in contact with him.
Yeah I have a video tape of you that he recorded of you working at the museum of philography down in the lab.
Oh well you know that'd be good to see that.
Yeah.
I may I may take a few snippets of that of at some point and uh show people Oh no that would be great.
Would you like that?
Yeah yeah absolutely.
That uh might look a little young though so it'd be horrify Yeah how how the years go, huh?
Yeah, right they fly past.
If you don't mind me asking how old are you now?
Oh twenty eight mana I'm forty five now because uh I find quite scary.
Yeah.
I'm gonna hit fifty in January.
Right.
That's really scary.
That's it, you know, it's almost like, you know this is the last part of my life now.
That's it.
It's true though.
It's true.
Yeah, no, no, we've still got lots of years in there, twenty, thirty.
Yeah, but I don't know, it's all it's all an attitude.
I imagine I'm still gonna be working away when I'm seventy five.
I'll never finish work.
I'll be w I'll be working when I pass pass away.
I mean, things go a little you know, progress takes a little longer, you know.
But uh we're still working away.
Mm-hmm.
Let me ask you this.
Do you find more excitement in holography now or back when you you were uh uh say younger at n in New York?
I think I still find it just as exciting.
Mm-hmm.
And um What about the response of people to holography?
There's seems to be almost a uh drought of exhibits and Yeah, well, I mean the the response of people uh to holography seems to be equally as uh amazing, you know, and there's a whole load of people that come in and say, Wow, I've never seen anything like it.
Yeah, still to this day, huh?
Yeah, yeah.
Well and they haven't seen them, you see, 'cause they've you know, they they're coming up, you know, twenty year old maybe haven't seen holograms like that.
Mm-hmm.
'Cause I haven't been around.
And uh it's it's kinda different working in it now because um before it was definitely on the cutting edge of technology.
Well now i it it's just different, yeah.
Yeah.
And a lot of competing technologies.
Yeah, yeah.
Well it doesn't seem high tech anymore, it just seems different, which is probably a good thing for holography because you know, philography suffered from anything that was being kind of over I don't know, uh f uh what's the word I'm looking for, like uh people expected too much from it, they expected Star Trek and things like that.
Yeah, project projected entertainment within their living rooms and things of that nature.
And now that's you know, not not it doesn't have such a reputation to live up to.
Unfortunately you still get the odd thing in the papers where someone says, Oh, and they're gonna be holographic projections and you have to explain to people that no, they're not holographic projections, you know, there's something else, you know.
So it still has that problem.
But uh I mean people a lot of people had a very negative conceptual idea of holography, you know, because of all these promises that it failed to keep up to.
But now I know got a new generation of people coming up and they all seem very excited about it.
And uh we'll see and also holographies doing very well in the art world at the moment, you know.
We've got um James Terrell showing his holograms as major art pieces.
Where are those shows at?
Uh where he recently showed some at the Royal Academy in London show.
But I think he's showing all over the world.
Now most of these folks are artists in the traditional sense that they've worked with uh other media and holography just piqued in interest and they decided to do a few pieces with holography.
Yeah, yeah.
That's been the case for so many years.
Yeah.
I had mixed feelings about that, but I guess, you know.
Yeah, I I think uh most holographers probably do, but it's not only holography.
I mean, most big name artists will commission studios to make their work, you know.
I had an art studio, an artist studio not long ago and my neighbour all he did was make work for a famous artist, you know.
And he was a sculptor, so it's it's not just in holography.
It's it's a bit annoying that holographers per se have been able to get large shows for themselves on the back of their own work.
Yeah.
But I think it it goes across the board.
I mean, art is a business and uh uh for better or for worse or whatever, and it's um a lot of the people that make, you know, the money are peop people getting other people to make their work for them, you know.
Yeah.
So it's not always like that, yeah.
But anyway.
So what are your future plans?
I mean, ten years from now where do you see Patrick Boyd?
Well, um well, hopefully uh running a very successful holography school.
Okay.
With um courses more than once a month.
Now will you instruct do you plan on instructing these courses yourself or do you see the day come when you're instructing most of the things you'll be more in administrative position.
Well um organizing it and instructing it and also um getting guest teachers in in Yakibstein is the only one so far, but hopefully that'll increase the other specialisms.
Mm-hmm.
So someone coming in downstairs very nice.
That's okay.
And it's good to s it's good to hear people.
Yes, yes, there's people here, yeah.
There's um there's quite a lot going on here.
And uh yeah also, you know, I'm still interested in shooting um photographic footage for holograms and making holograms again.
Do you see the day when you will have no choice but to move on to digital holography?
Um no I think there's a there's a there's a future for traditional holography.
I mean you can tell the difference when you look at a digital hologram.
And uh also Yeah no no no I can't I can't say uh I can just see uh traditional holography at the moment.
Yeah at the moment I mean, you even when you make a digital hologram you uh you still have to um well unless you get someone else to make it for you, you know, um there's still a lot of technology involved.
Yeah.
It's all swings and roundabouts really.
I imagine the printer would be the most expensive part of the uh of that process.
Yeah, I mean basically, um when you make a digital hologram you have a you know it's there's a s a setup involved and uh yeah, I mean well they are they're extremely these di digital holographic printers or whatever are extremely expensive.
Yeah.
Who's manufacturing those?
Uh well we do here.
Oh you're manufacturing.
That that's the main core of uh business is the technology.
Making these machines now.
And the folks that are purchasing them, the companies, uh what are the applications that they're using them for?
If you're security and metric.
Yeah, tickets and things like that.
Well, I want to wish you a lot of luck, continued success.
It's been a long time since we've had a chance to talk to one another.
How's Allentown?
Allentown's doing well.
Still have the same house.
Yes, excellent.
You know, my wife and I put a a lot of years into uh refurbishing the house.
The the girls like we had like I spoke to you on Saturday, they're they're grown.
Yeah.
And uh out of the house and uh you got it back to yourself now.
How many children do you have?
Two, two.
What are their ages?
Uh Hamish is twelve and Tapitha's ten.
Wow.
Hey, which was famously featured in the hologram.
Okay.
Mhm.
And uh but it doesn't seem to have affected him too much.
Yeah.
Uh he's still doing well.
And uh yeah, no, but if you ever hear of Bardas, let us know what he's up to.
Yeah, I've looked him up a couple of times on the web and I found a few things, but uh nothing that was current.
Yeah.
I try to find everybody.
Yeah, I'll go he'll surface at some point.
Alright, well uh just to let the whole talk listeners know, we have uh links on the website to uh Patrick's workshop programs and they're running now in London and uh you can become a part of those because they're running around the calendar year, the last week of each month.
Excellent, excellent.
All right.
I'll send you the the address for the my personal holography website.
Patrick, thank you.
Uh my pleasure.
I'm sure the uh listeners are very happy to hear your voice, and that's what HoloTalk's all about.
You know, we read about all these people on the web, but we don't really get a chance to hear them or hear them speak and this gives them uh everyone an opportunity to actually put a human element to uh these h holographers that everyone reads about.
Okay.
All right.
Brilliant, brilliant.
Now I'm gonna have to gem up on my technology and work out how to download this to my iPod as well.
Oh, yeah, that's just an automatic process.
I I mean there's there's a thing now where you can hook your iPod up and it'll just uh download the show overnight and it'll be waiting for you in the morning.
Oh dear.
Isn't that amazing?
I'm I'm getting emails from people t that listen to them uh going to work in the morning on the buses and stuff and it's a whole new ball game now.
Doing well, doing well, the site still looks good.
Yeah.
Excellent.
All right.
Okay, listen.
Speak to you soon.
Okay, take care, Patrick.
Thanks.
Bye.
Bye then.